- I have to ask.
I heard that your first ever
concert was pretty amazing.
You wanna tell everybody who that was?
- First ever, oh, what
a come around moment
with the Jackson 5.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- Yes.
- Somebody told me that,
'cause I always ask, 'cause
obviously I'm a musician,
so I always ask like what people go see
and that's your first concert?
- Yes, and my sister and
I were in North Carolina.
My poor uncle.
He had gotten us tickets.
- Yeah.
- And they got great
tickets 'cause we were
in like the first or second row.
- What?
- We had our little,
you know, bolero jacket,
hot pants and Samson and Delilah sandals.
And I swear, they looked
right at me and sang the song
and it was just great.
And then many, many, many
years later when I decided
to become an actress, to play
Miss Katherine, their mom.
- Oh my God.
- And she was just, she's
an absolute delight.
- What a full circle.
- Delight.
And I remember being at the
Image Awards and Miss Katherine
walked by and it was
like, and we would sit,
have lunch and look at
the clouds and talk.
Such a mother.
- Yeah.
- Such you know, inspiration.
And so she stopped and Michael
and he turned around like mom
and he came back and he was
like, oh you were wonderful.
And I was that 12 year old all over again.
- [Kelly] Isn't that crazy?
When stuff like that happens?
- It's rolling me back.
I was just like, oh my God,
his hand is in my hand.
- Oh, that's so cool.
And what a, I just can't say it enough.
It's a very rad first concert.
I was like, I don't know
if anybody can beat that.